Thank you.
you all right good morning everybody welcome to eda day we have two non-germain amendments to our Senate bills that are some of the issues we've been working on all spring, and Representative Broda will introduce them.
Melissa, first one.
Yes, thank you, Madam Chair.
I'm introducing an amendment, non-jermaine amendment to Senate Bill 207.
And it is to provide conditional licensure for mental health professionals.
And this originally was called House Bill 428 and we retained it in committee.
And I'm hoping that we could take a look at it and discuss it and attach it to Senate Bill 207.
It came out of the work committee that we had over the summer to remove the hurdles for the mental health professionals in New Hampshire.
Okay.
So we have conditional licenses.
And perhaps...
Did this come out of...
Was this in House Bill 2, and did we take it out of House Bill 2?
No.
I don't believe so.
Did we?
I don't think so.
Okay.
Thank you.
This is for just...
This is something...
I don't believe we have a statute that deals with applications for conditional licensure.
Ah, so this is new law.
Yes, exactly.
Okay.
Thank you.
Are there any questions from the committee?
All right.
Thank you very much representative thank you all right I don't have any card so is there anyone else who wishes to testify on this amendment good morning good morning uh representative i have a pin card i can give you um for the record lindsay courtney executive director office of professional licensure and certification um oklc is here to testify in support of Amendment 1915H.
Essentially, several years ago, we had added conditional licensure for certain license types under the Board of Mental Health Practice, but we did not include all license types under the Board of Mental Health Practice.
Historically, what they've done is they've had approved supervisory agreements and then they have been allowed to practice under supervision without seeking licensure this would allow them to obtain a conditional license under the same parameters but i think it would essentially provide a mechanism to bill and receive reimbursement for services, which is the direction this state is going it's also consistent with what we see in other states and it's consistent with the compacts that are starting to come out which require um certain categories for licensure with that i'd be happy to answer any questions but but it's pretty straightforward.
Okay.
Are there any questions from the committee?
Representative Fitzpatrick?
Hello.
Representative Perota.
I have a comment, if I may.
One of the reasons why the committee had retained the bill was because we were looking at House Bill 655 and the merger of the mental health boards.
And until we had addressed that, we didn't want to add any more requirements or definitions to the mental health professions.
But I do think that at this point, we are ready to do that.
Okay.
Anyone else?
All right, Thank you very much.
Is there anyone else who wishes to testify on this amendment to Senate Bill 207?
okay in that case i'll close the public hearing and we will result we will chatter and lobby until 11 o'clock when our next hearing begins what i thought so too but let's a Matt and Jason can't be here today.
So she's got work, I think.
She had work.
So I don't know where everybody else is either, but I'm this this one.
Thank you.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
Amendment number 2023-1943 is something that might look familiar to some of you.
Some of it is from the original House Bill 655, which was heard in this committee, and deals with four things.
One is the repealing of the disciplinary proceedings from the boards and investigations.
You might remember that the discussion that we had had as a committee was to separate investigation from adjudication.
So, investigations is going to be conducted by OPLC.
The other part of the amendment addresses non-public members because not all of the statutes made it clear that non-public members had to be independent from the...
Excuse me, you mean public members?
I mean public members.
I'm so sorry.
That's no problem.
Public members.
Thank you.
So those public members have to be independent from the board.
The other refers to what used to be the Medical Review Subcommittee.
Lastly, it talks about the requirements of being a board member and what the reasons would be to be removed from a board and this amendment was drafted by attorney Osterhout from OPLC, and he's here to answer any questions that you might have.
Okay.
Are there any questions from the committee?
Representative True, thank you.
Thank you, Madam Chair.
I apologize.
You listed four things it's doing.
What was the third?
The Medical Review Subcommittee, which was eliminated but is redefined in this amendment.
Thank you.
Review Subcommittee, which was eliminated but is redefined in this amendment.
Yes, the Medical Review Subcommittee is on page 10, the bottom of page 10.
Okay.
and I see that you've got a contingent effectivity so that this applies after House Bill 655 passes thank you that makes it easier I'm going to go, and Jackie can correct me if I'm wrong, the members appointed by the medical board and so there's some concern I had some concern of having the same people doing the investigation who would then basically adjudicate it and if you look at page 10 starting at line 32 it, the committee appointments shall be made by the executive director of OPLC in accordance with the criteria established by the board.
So the board can say what kind of people they need, what kind of expertise, but they don't actually appoint the individuals to deal with that potential issue.
Okay.
On the public members, did you get the entire Board of mental health practice I there's the pharmacy board and the midwifery council okay I'm not sure everyone was able to hear what I said but Douglas Osterhhout, OPLC.
I went through every single board under the OPLC for this project.
Okay, thank you.
That's important.
Yeah, I was shocked when I was told that one member was the spouse of another member.
And that appears to a lot of people that looks like that's a conflict of interest.
All right, any other questions, comments?
All right, well, thank you very much.
Is there anyone else who wishes to testify on this amendment all right seeing none i will close the public hearing we will be voting on these bills on wednesday and these amendments will be part of the executive session.
Okay, thank you all for coming.
Thank you.